we're now
heading into the month of april 2021
so it's time for another monthly update
video i'm going to talk about
what we've got coming up in april and
what you might have missed in march i'll
put links to all of those things all you
have to do is click the show
more for the video description and
you'll find links to
all of these things either coming up or
already passed but recorded that you can
check
out so i always like to begin by
highlighting three big things and we
actually do have
three pretty big things this this month
that you might want to
give some attention to so the first
thing
is worldwide it's kind of a big deal for
the stoic community this is
the 1900th birthday of marcus aurelius
the stoic
emperor and so there'll be all sorts of
events and celebrations and cool stuff
going on
more about that in the april section
second thing that happened in march so
big thing number two
is i passed a hundred thousand
subscribers
on my main youtube channel
so you know thanks to everybody who
subscribed and this is a milestone that
has been 10 years in the making kind of
a big deal
last thing big thing number three i'm
going to be
bringing out at least one new class in
the study for sadler
academy so you may want to check that
out
as well there's some other classes
some that you can pay for some that are
free in there that can help you study
philosophy
and you know dip your feet into the
world of ideas
so those are the three big things let's
talk now about march
march is a long month and i thought i'd
get a lot more done than i did
in february not banking on the fact that
there's only three more days in march
than there are in february and
i did get you know quite a few of the
things that i set myself as goals
accomplished but
not not all of them you know sometimes
maybe i'll have to do a video sometimes
about
how to deal with not meeting your
uh goals and tasks that you set for
yourself and how to how to still be
productive and have a positive attitude
i did do you know quite a few events
my monthly ama that's ask me anything my
patreon supporter philosophy chat the
half hour hegel sessions i did a
political theory
and practice discussion on thomas hobbes
and leviathan
we held our monthly chapter meetings of
the milwaukee stoic
fellowship and the milwaukee that
society of philosophers in america
and i um started what what's the first
of
three uh you know worlds of speculative
fiction
segments that are devoted specifically
to r scott backer's
monumental trilogy the prince of nothing
which is part of his larger
second apocalypse series seven books so
far
and that went pretty well we also had a
great classic metal class
uh on you know metal in
the los angeles area in
the uh late 70s early to mid 80s that
was that was a lot of fun
and i actually did a clubhouse um
event the very first one with massimo
pigliucci
uh focused on stoics and the pandemic
and
my co-host dan hayes and i both we were
both able to
log in together and we got two wisdom
for
life sessions in so that that's quite
good
as well that's the radio show that we
host for riverwest radio
as far as video production goes um i
you know i mentioned i didn't hit all of
the goals that i'd set i
got two half hour hegel videos done out
of the six that i would have preferred
to have
done one book review out of the four
that i was shooting for but i did do a
lot
of core concept videos and i've released
most of those
some on thomas hobbs um also
on lucian of sam samos soda
there we go xenophon dealing with
antisthenes diogenes laertes dealing
with
antisthenes and diogenes the cynic from
sinope
and a couple from julian the emperor
who was also talking about cynic
philosophy and then i've been
releasing videos that i shot on
friedrich nature's genealogy of morals
for
my my classes that i have this semester
so it's still actually quite a lot and
all the event videos
i also did a caption contest video
because fans were calling for that
i did a sort of i did two sort of
impromptu videos as well
one was spurred by a twitter discussion
that got quite polemical actually
started out polemical
uh with with uh nigel warburton tweeting
that
if you can't be clear about philosophy
then you should quit philosophy and so i
i
turned that into an interesting video
that quite a few people
commented on it it's still ongoing at
this point
i'll put a link to that one below and
just uh
just a few days ago i was taking a walk
and i saw some rowing teams on the
milwaukee river
video recorded they're rowing because my
my wife enjoys watching that sort of
thing and
and then thought other people might like
it as well found a great soundtrack to
pair with it
and so that video has been getting quite
a bit of traction as well
it has been a very busy month
you know students are requiring a lot of
attention
and work in the classes that i'm
teaching
i started a eight week intensive
online class at uh milwaukee area
technical college that you know began in
mid-march uh four other classes
ongoing and in full swing in the month
and interestingly i've been getting a
lot of additional
new clients for philosophical counseling
tutorials
um coaching and consulting
and so that's you know that's kind of a
good thing but it's really been
intense this this this time as well as
keeping up with all my
older clients and collaborators so
and i've been working on some writing
stuff you know i released a few things
in medium
i'm working on my paper for the saint
anselm conference which we'll talk about
in the april part that's going to be a
lot of fun
so a lot of things going on podcast
production
you may have noticed that i did a vote
and
people weighed in and and you know first
i was releasing
podcast episodes on seneca
and david hume after that i said okay
who do people want me to
work on next and i gave them four
choices and they chose thomas hobbs
followed by
and some of canterbury and then several
others and so that's that's who i've
been releasing podcasts on
uh in the last uh month as well so
pretty busy month in in march we have a
pretty packed month as far as the
calendar goes
in april so coming up this very weekend
we have three events the first is and
all of these are in central time by the
way so you've got to make sure that you
check your time zones and
account for daylight savings time and
all that other sort of stuff if you're
not
in the united states so at on the third
which is saturday at 12 p.m we have our
monthly
ama that's ask me anything session
make sure that you get your questions in
early you don't have to ask
the same question twice because if you
you know
ask it twice it's not going to get
answered twice and
you'll probably annoy some of the other
participants so you know good questions
obviously you might want to watch some
of the earlier amas to see if some of
them have been answered already
coming up after that at 2 pm on the 3rd
i have a much more intimate session
video conferencing
in philosophy chat that is a perk for
some of my patreon supporters if you're
interested in that you know you can
look at the link below and become a
patron
and uh then you can get in on that that
nice session where you can same sort of
thing
ask me anything but it's just you and
whoever else comes in
and and me and we talk about things in a
more sustained way
at uh 12 p.m on the 4th
that sunday i'm going to have a party a
little online party
to celebrate having reached 100 000
subscribers
on youtube and it'll be us live
streaming i'm gonna talk a little bit
about you know
how long how it took me 10 years to get
there um
some of my plans for the youtube channel
that i'm going to have going forward
particularly starting
this summer once once classes are over
and you know take comments and questions
from people and
maybe we'll have a toast or something
like that so if you can join me that
that'd be really
great on the sixth that's a wednesday or
a tuesday
rather 6 p.m the chapter meeting of mke
sophia that's the society of
philosophers in america
milwaukee session we meet by zoom so you
don't have to be
from milwaukee as a matter of fact we
have people joining us
from all over the world sometimes for
these these sessions
on the 10th at uh 12 p.m and then at 1
30 we have a two-part event worlds of
speculative fiction
we will be looking at our scott backer's
second book
of his prince of nothing trilogy the
warrior prophet
in which kellehus becomes as we say the
warrior prophet a lot of cool
stuff going on in that amazing
book um if you're not a fan of our scott
backer
because you haven't read him i would
strongly suggest getting into
his stuff he was a philosophy graduate
student
before he and he was you know ready to
work out his dissertation before he
left and started um putting these these
books into print that had been he'd been
working on for years and years
so that's a good thing we begin with a
video premiere
at 12 noon and then we have a
follow-up zoom session at 1 30 where we
go more into the themes
of the book on the 11th the next day at
12 p.m we'll have our political theory
and practice discussion this time we're
going to be tackling something
very controversial but not as
controversial if you actually read the
text which i'm going to direct people
towards and that's talking about
aristotle and his views on
slavery something that has drawn a lot
of attention lately it's actually a lot
more complex and
not quite as exciting as people make it
out to be but
we'll get into that right
then on the 14th at 5 pm that's a
wednesday
we're going to have our public hegel q
a and discussion sessions so if you want
to talk hegel or
german idealism or philosophy in general
you can pop
on into that jumping ahead to the
weekend
on the 17th that's a saturday at 10 a.m
we're going to be having a event
studying the stoics and focused
specifically on how to pro how to get
the most out of reading marcus
aurelius's meditations
fits in with the 1900 year birthday
celebration
that's an event that we'll be having
before the actual
birthday uh that you might want to get
in on if you if you've read the
meditations and you're not quite sure
what you're working with or if you've
never read the meditations and you want
to know more
about how best to study it and some tips
for that sort of thing
you definitely want to go to that event
following that at
12 p.m we are going to have our classic
metal class me and scott taruli this
time around we're going to be talking
german metal and we're going to be
talking german metal in the 1970s
into the mid-80s so we're not going to
be talking about
lots and lots of genre stuff later on
we're going to be talking about classic
heavy metal
so you know obviously scorpions and
accept will be
pretty heavily featured in the
discussion but there's many other bands
and uh interesting developments to talk
about
as well and some cross fertilization
between uh
you know germany the rest of europe
japan
britain and america and also south
america
as well so if you're interested in heavy
metal we're going to be doing some music
history stuff
and geeking out a little bit two fellow
metal heads who both have
backgrounds me and philosophy scott in
actually
he's a practicing musician with several
albums
and he teaches that at berkeley school
of music he's a guitar professor
so you're going to be getting the really
good stuff if you show up to that
on the 23rd
at 10 30 a.m i will be giving a talk
in the st anselm's
conference at st anselm college
obviously i'm going to be doing so
remotely the whole thing is on zoom
and it's a very cheap call it's a very
cheap um
conference to register for usually
academic conferences are quite expensive
because this is all online ten dollars
you can you can hear me talk about
anselm and a whole bunch of other cool
people
that i'm really looking forward to
hearing uh you know barents goalball
maria coalish thomas williams
my a lot of friends and colleagues
presenting so
you might want to check that out as well
then on the 25th at 3 p.m
there's an event at the new acropolis
again
online event and it's focused on marcus
aurelius and
celebrating his 1900th birthday
i'll be talking specifically about what
marcus has to
tell us about anger understanding it
managing it some advice
about that and jill my my co-host will
be talking about
some other related topic then we'll take
questions from the crowd it should be
recorded i hope as well and
then there's also on the 29th at 6 p.m
the
mke that's milwaukee stoic fellowship
again
people from all over the world join us
now you know
the last session we had somebody from
minneapolis we had two of us from
milwaukee
somebody from uh las vegas and i'm i'm
blanking on where the other person
was from but sometimes we have people
popping in from brazil
or or you know other places outside of
the us you're welcome to join us we're
working through cicero's on duties and
we're going to be talking specifically
about the stoics conception of
high-mindedness great soldness you know
magnifice
and courage the virtue of courage
the other thing i'll point out is that
every saturday at 4 pm
central you can hear me and my co-host
dan
hayes talking about matters practical
and philosophical on the wisdom for life
radio show
we generally do two new episodes a month
and so
some you know sometimes they're playing
older episodes but they're all good
and they're all there to help you live a
better life so
you can tune in worldwide just by going
to
the riverwest radio wxrw
104.1 website and you can click listen
live and you can hear us
streaming worldwide
got a lot of video work to do this this
month
and so i'm going to be you know trying
to get
half hour hegel videos in the religion
section done get back to some book
review videos
i think i would like to start doing some
sadler's stories
videos again i didn't do any of those
last month i was just a little too busy
and we'll do another caption contest
there'll be videos of all of these
events as well as of the recording
sessions from
wisdom for life i'm going to be
recording
well releasing more nietzsche videos
recording some videos
on some bits about freud and
psychoanalysis for one of my classes
i've got a few fanon videos yet to shoot
that i didn't get to
in the past that i i really would like
to get to
and in the podcast i'm going to be
releasing some and some vid
podcasts and some podcasts then i
have to do work on fun own taking those
lecture videos and converting them into
podcast episodes
that's a lot of work because as it
turned out i went very long
and talking about some of them are
almost half an hour long
and then i've got lev shestoff videos to
convert into podcast episodes
and then we'll take another vote we'll
we'll uh see
you know i'll say here's four more
choices who do you want me to work on
first and that's what we'll do now the
one last thing that i'll close on
mentioning i brought up the study with
sadler reason io academy i have online
classes for those
who would like to study with me and
don't want to enroll
in you know expensive academic classes
but want some of the same sort of
content
go to the study with sadler academy and
you'll see things
available there i'm working on some new
classes
for that that i'll be releasing later on
this month so those of you who
have a hankering for something a little
bit more structured than just podcast
episodes or videos
well we've got online courses that you
can you can take
and you can enroll and then stay on top
of new releases as they come out
so that is the that's everything that's
going on this this upcoming month
uh now that i think about it it's quite
a lot hope i see you at some of these
online events and
yeah hopefully hope you can join me for
the celebration of hitting a hundred
thousand subscribers
you